well so many people across the valley
have really been hit financially by the
covid pandemic
but today hundreds of families receive
some help eight sports now's kevin
martin was out at this community event
today and joins us live with more hey
kevin
well hey sasha you know so many families
have been impacted by this pandemic and
one of the main issues is food
insecurity prior to the pandemic
southern nevada saw
one in eight people who were food
insecure
that number has now grown to one in six
and helped fight this pandemic
they're the raiders along with mgm
resorts and three square food bank
teamed up today to help give back they
distributed hundreds of family-sized
food bags this morning at western high
school over 400 families
drove through as volunteers including
raiders president mark madane and mgm
resorts president
and ceo bill hornbuckle loaded up the
cars with everything from cereal to
packaged meat and rice
each car received an equivalent of
around 40 meals
mark bedame said he knows times are
tough for many but reminded us that
vegas is strong
this is a very resilient community it
always has been it's bounced back from a
lot of situations
and this is one that i think it will
bounce back even stronger
you can see it already you can see it
starting to happen you can see the
the people in the community make that
kind of thing happen get together and
start working on plans for how they're
going to reopen vegas and
and really celebrate the reopening of
vegas so i'm glad we're a part of it and
i'm glad we're here
and if you want to get involved and help
go to threesquare dot org now every
dollar that you donate now
turns into six meals for someone in need
right here in the las vegas community
sasha